joining us right now is General David
Perkins Fox News contributor four-star
retired four-star Army General General
Perkins how significant is this kill
well good evening Brian I mean this is
great news not only for the U.S but for
the entire world and uh my hats off to
the great men and women that were
uniform as well as the intelligence
agencies that were able to bring him to
Justice he has been a problem for us all
the way back to the USS Cole various
Embassy bombings all that so this is a
major victory for the war on terrorism
no doubt about it he was the right-hand
man and inspirational and deep thinker
alongside Bin Laden for years in fact he
was in and arrested after the Anwar
Sadat assassination that's how long he's
been at it but zawar hearing the fact
that he was living in a residential
neighborhood in Kabul out in the open
and that they've been eyeing him for
months what does that tell you about the
Comfort he felt in Afghanistan's Capital
to make you make you understand the role
that Al Qaeda has with that new
government
well this is a uh point of possible
concern that obviously he really
couldn't be there moving around without
some knowledge of that the Taliban
having some knowledge of it the yet
unanswered question and probably best
not to be answered publicly is did we
get any inside information or help from
the Taliban uh
that's the the unknown part right now
and probably best maybe if publicly is
not known but that is the problem with
you know the this transnational
terrorism is it to be successful it
requires some Safe Haven some area of
support from some national capability
and that's always the challenge that we
have globally
in general Over the Horizon worked in
this case but how much better would have
been if we had some type of presence
this way it wouldn't be Terry University
uh right next door real quick it in your
estimation was Bin Laden in charge when
we killed him and was zawahiri in charge
of Al Qaeda when we killed him
well I think uh Bin Laden probably was
sort of the figurehead uh probably not
involved in the day-to-day operations
are we here he always has been as you
said sort of the the master planner and
operator pulling all the pieces together
working the logistics and so they each
had specific roles so so him leaving the
scene uh both as the designated leader
and you know really follower or Bin
Laden as well as the key operator over
decades is a major hit to Al Qaeda
hey uh General it was great to catch up
with you uh thanks so much for joining
us tonight appreciate it we're going to
talk China but this breaking news you're
able to ride with because you lived it
for the last 20 years thanks hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else